We are going to have plenty of time over the
next couple of months to do very detailed
postmortems of this election, but I think that
one aspect of this that I want to put in front
of you right away before before the final vote is
even done is we have confirmed beyond any doubt
that Donald Trump's 2016 win was not a fluke. This
was not a fluke. Now, with Donald Trump getting
more than 69 million votes already approaching 70
million votes other than Joe Biden this same year,
who currently has over 73 million votes,
no candidate has ever gotten more votes
than Donald Trump got this year. So this was
not a fluke. Trump ism is not an aberration
in the sense of it came out of nowhere and it will
disappear very, very quickly. Trump ism exposed
to things, the horrible reality of about 40
percent of this country. That's horrible.
But there's the other side, which is that
the Democratic Party really doesn't get it.
I think the election results prove that
the Democratic Party doesn't get it.
And if they don't start to get it,
the Democratic Party is going to fail
and fail when they could very easily do far
better. And as I said on the livestream yesterday,
we have to be able to hold both ideas in our minds
at the same time. Yes, the Democratic Party has
things to fix because this is an election that
should have gone much better for them given the
facts on the ground. And yes, there is a huge side
of the electorate on the Trump side that doesn't
care about the facts on the ground. But it doesn't
matter as long as we can acknowledge that Trump
getting millions more votes this year than he
did last time shows us this is not a fluke. Now,
Donald Trump presented to people something that
was appealing, which is a guy who won't, you know,
make them feel bad about their gas guzzling
trucks and their guns and their religiosity and
their sometimes self selected ignorance about a
number of different issues. I'm not saying that
Donald Trump genuinely was those things. I don't
think Trump likes pickup trucks. I don't think
Trump is religious. I don't think Trump is against
abortion. You know, it doesn't matter. Trump just
gave them someone to say, OK, this is someone that
that we can get around here. And Trump almost won
despite coronavirus the economy cartoonish,
embarrassing, humiliating incompetence,
Trump almost won in 2020. The way in which
Trump won the 2016 primary was weird. It was
circuitous. He benefited from a number of
factors, including timing, racist sentiment
against Barack Obama. And his birther ism was
you know, there were a lot of little factors that
from 17 in 2016, Republican candidates to 16, 15,
and Trump just outlasted everybody else. But then
you look at 20, 20 and you see he got millions
more votes. 69 million Americans who chose to vote
chose Trump over Joe Biden. Trump's humiliating
track record on coronavirus didn't matter to
nearly half of the people that voted in this
election, according to Pew Research Center data
compiled by Zero Media. The economy was the most
important issue in 2016 and in 2020. Health care.
The Supreme Court became more important
between elections, foreign policy, guns
and immigration became less important. So with
many different top issues this time versus 2016
and a disastrous performance by Trump objectively
on coronavirus, Trump increased his support by
millions of votes. So we cannot if we see this as
a fluke, then we lose hugely. I'm not saying that
a lot of Trump ists aren't deplorable. They
are. I'm not saying a lot of Trump is aren't
ignorant. They are. I'm not saying a lot of Trump
is are good people because many of them are not.
Many are one, two or all three of those things.
But if the left right continues to write off Trump
ism as merely a fluke because of what happened in
the 2016 Republican primary and the 2016 election,
it is wrong and the Democratic Party will continue
to lose and the left will continue to lose. There
are two sides to this. We have to understand their
movement. We have to understand how the Democratic
Party is failing the left. It is two sided and
yes, the electoral system is broken. I get it. If
we had a popular vote system, Hillary wins easily
in 2016 and Biden wins even more easily in 2020.
But the fact that anyone could vote for Donald
Trump is a huge part of the issue. He's getting
forty eight percent of the popular vote. Our
problems are way worse than the electoral
system and a lot of it is education. But
a lot of it is the left misunderstanding
this entire movement. And just because we can
all agree it's a disgusting, deplorable movement,
that's fine. I'm not arguing with that. I've been
the first one, not the I've been saying it for.
Four years, but if we want to win and win big, and
that means take resounding control of the Senate,
take resounding control of the House and get
significant policy done on health care, climate,
etc., We have to understand the movement,
even if it's a disgusting movement.
And right now, it does not seem that the
Democratic Party understands this movement
and will have plenty more time to discuss
it. I just want to kind of plant that seed.